so yeah again Jenna this is parsing
cursors and I am a senior front-end
engineer at slack I'm on the search and
discovery team we're based in New York
City I spend a lot of time thinking
about the quick switcher and other art
of completes throughout the product some
other things I do in New York include
organizing to JavaScript communities one
is Empire Jas which is an annual
JavaScript conference yeah there is
Brooklyn Jas which is a monthly
JavaScript Meetup
so I know firsthand how much effort it
takes to pull off an event like this so
can we get a round of applause for all
with organizers volunteers and everyone
else so my twitter handle is Zygon
vector you can feel free to tweet
questions comments and compliments at me
there I'll also tweet out the link to my
slides which just happens to be on this
slide she also mentioned there's a lot
of information here so I've included
some citations at the bottom of my
bottom of my slides there's probably
like entire college courses on parsers
but I have to do this in 25 minutes so
there's gonna be a lot of information in
a short amount of time some of its going
to be high-level some of its gonna be
fast sorry
so if you want to learn more please
check out those links all right let's
parse some parsers so I think to really
understand parsers like understand what
they're doing we need to learn a little
bit about what makes languages language
what makes languages languages so we'll
talk a little bit about that and then as
I was building the talk I just realized
that the best way to learn about parsers
is to build one which we will be
stepping through the code for because
I'm not brave enough to live code on
stage so it'll be small it'll be a
little too a parser but hopefully you
can learn some things that I learned and
feel the joy that I felt while building
it so let's learn about language
language is a structured system of
communication might seem obvious
we're starting at the basics here so we
are using language to encode information
to send between two entities like two
people two computers a person and a
computer etc the language that we're
used to is called natural language we
humans we speak it we sign it we write
it we understand it innately because our
brains evolved to understand it there
are rules that govern how we put words
together and how we put letters together
to form words but we don't necessarily
know these rules explicitly we might
learn them in English class or in
whatever class like that where you learn
the rules of grammar but we don't
necessarily know these rules explicitly
some of these rules might be that now
it's combined with verbs an adverb might
come in to modify that verb but again we
understand language and we've learned
these rules without ever even really
trying because our brains have evolved
seamlessly to acquire language and even
if we break these rules it's okay you
generally understand what the other
person is trying to say formal languages
on the other hand are a bit more well
formal they're more math class than
English or Spanish class formal
languages are also made up of words that
are made up of letters from an alphabet
both of which can be combined at each
level based on specific rules which is
called the languages grammar programming
languages are formal languages which
mean to that they have an alphabet like
unicode and a grammar which we sometimes
called the syntax that tells us how to
write our code all the way down to the
punctuation so as I said languages
grammar is the set of rules for that
language formal grammars put these rules
in terms of rules of replacement which
are called production rules so to get a
sense of what I mean by replacement
let's take a look at this little
sentence diagram for this very short
sentence Jenna gave the talk so we can
kind of see that a sentence can be
broken down into a noun and a verb
phrase a verb phrase can
replaced by a verb and a noun phrase etc
all the way down the line so here are
these rules put another way so you can
see that sentence now a plus verb phrase
verb phrase verb plus noun phrase down
phrase can be broken down into a direct
object and a noun and neither of these
can be broken down any further
programming languages have their
grammars defined in a spec if any of you
have ever been brave enough to try and
read the Ekman script spec you might
have seen that there is a section on
grammars and a good chunk of it is
describing how we put the bits of
JavaScript together to create proper
JavaScript so let's start our journey
towards building our parser and first
define our language and its grammar so I
wanted to choose a language that had a
few moving parts that I knew well and
then I could explain how it works and
what it means so I chose a language that
was right there in front of me every day
seven days a week you might be familiar
with it it is the search query language
from slack if you're not familiar with
it explain what's going on here and our
goal ultimately will be to build an even
better visualizer
for this language so here's an example
of the search query language we have
there are terms here like JavaScript
phrases like front end in a single round
of quotation marks there's these filters
like in random and in general which say
which messages we want to find which
channels we want to search for messages
in and from filters like from Jenna you
want to find all the messages that are
from me so here's what this grammar is
going to look like a query can just be a
term you can search for just JavaScript
query can also be a term plus more query
if we were to lock JavaScript off the
beginning that would still be a valid
query query can just be a filter you
want to search for all the messages in
random you can just do that and then you
can search for all of the messages that
have the word JavaScript in them in the
random Channel and that's our little
grammar for our language then I want us
to build something that looks like
that highlights the different types of
bits of language in their own color
whether it be green purple or light pink
okay
parsers that's what we are all here for
so what what is a parser well it parses
which is the process of analyzing
language against the rules of its
grammar so we're going to take the
language and break it down into its
components to find its underlying
structure to see if it adheres to the
rules of the language that it was
written for this process also helps us
turn language into something the
computer can better use and maybe
understand if we're going to think about
it in human terms Bursar's can be really
complicated but in the end all they have
to do is take they all have to do is be
a function that takes raw input and
turns it into meaningful data that is
created from the input or it's going to
send off an error so again if it takes
some unstructured language and turns it
into something that is more structure
and is more meaningful that's a parser
Purser's
in general when they're more complicated
they usually have two parts to them they
have a lexer and a parser which is the
main event because you know it takes on
the whole word right so the lexer is
going to take the text and break it down
into meaningful units called tokens
these meaningful units are going to be
the words the punctuation etc the first
step in lexing is going to be the
scanner so it's going to go through and
break the string of characters into the
proper chunks Jirka lexemes and these
lexemes are the words in the language
they can be key words literals like a
number or string punctuation etc and
this process is often accomplished by
using Magilla expressions so let's dig
into some code
[Music]
all right so we have a regular
expressions here that define the four
types of things that we can have an in
filter from filter a phrase within those
quotation marks and just a single term
so just one word and this is pretty much
just gonna be our lexer it's going to
take those regular expressions and match
them against the string that we put in
so let's see what happens when we use
our example a little bit so we can see
here that these are our lexemes just
smaller strings made from the initial
input which was JavaScript front-end in
general from jena etc well so let's also
take a look at what javascript is doing
because that's also interesting so
javascript is going to take this little
snippet of code and turn it into
something that looks like this not very
different but you can see it's going to
break it down into its lexemes
which include just const the variable
name lexeme that equals sign which is
punctuation the next step is the
evaluator is going to combine the
lexemes type with its value to create a
token so first let's take a look at our
code and you can see this next little
bit so we're gonna take the tokens and
combine them with their type which we
can figure out because we know exactly
what an in token looks like based on its
regular expression or diff from token
looks like based on that and etc so we
can take those and turn them into the
types of tokens that they are which just
like a little object wrapper nothing too
complicated because again little
language little parser
so javascript is going to take its
lexemes like this and it's going to put
them up into the mash them up with their
type and turn them into these tokens and
shout out to spree mahir which is a very
popular parser that folks use for
javascript that back some of our
favorite JavaScript tools that do you
like source transformation demo tools
link at the bottom so if you want to you
know see how it shakes out with whatever
whatever your favorite snippet of
JavaScript is you can do that there and
this is what it is actually going to
spit out it's really simple it has this
type and it's the value never showed you
what our little parser ends up doing so
let's look at that hello tokens
it's either the tokens from our little
language so we have a term and in filter
C not too much more complicated but they
still have a little bit more meaning we
can you know that this is an in filter
you know this is a from filter and
that's something that the computer might
be able to do a little bit more with
than just those fair strings that we had
from lexemes
all right so now we're onto the main
event the parser which is going to
analyze the tokens that were produced by
the lexer checking that the syntax is
correct based on the prescribed rules of
the language while creating again that
structure based on the production rules
the result of parsing is usually a tree
you might have heard about parse trees
or syntax trees so that's what usually
gets created and then if the parser
cannot create a tree you end up with a
syntax error so what we're gonna want
out of this is a tree that kind of looks
like this because that's what we need to
build our visualizer parsers in the end
or just around to help us achieve our
end we can build a parser in different
ways to achieve different goals
and this is all we need we need to know
that all of these tokens wrap up into a
single query so let's take a look at our
code and how it ends up spitting out our
little tree so I'm gonna actually go to
PS code okay so our parser isn't
actually that much more complicated so
we're gonna take we're gonna make a base
query which is going to be our top level
and just give it the tokens because
that's all that we need to create our
parser the way that we need it to be
created creating this tree structure for
our visualizer so then let's take a look
at what it spits out Oh parse tree we
have tokens top levels the query and
then the tokens are here spit out we
just have the single level these don't
get broken down any further we are at
the end cool so Java Script or something
a little bit more complicated here going
to have this program that eventually
filters down into this tree of the you
know I can't help but notice that like
the leaves here are the thing that
really matters right like we have like
the variable names at the bottom the
strings the method names that's like the
stuff that really has meaning to us and
then the rest of it was just there to
help the purser figure out what was
going on and this is what a stream is
going to spit out it's a lot for such a
little snippet of JavaScript and this I
had to cut it off so you could even have
a fighting chance of reading any of it
so it's a lot but anything that helps us
helps the computer make our JavaScript
to do what we want it to do come to
throw a little curveball into our little
language here I think that we should
I like these tokens these entities
because they're they're their own
separate meaningful unit right so what
do we have to do to make our visualizer
be able to do this well first we have to
change our grammar around a little bit
before we had it so that a filter
couldn't be broken down any further but
now it can into a modifier and an entity
which they themselves could not be
broken down anymore and then our tree is
going to end up looking like this a
little bit more complicated one more
layer surely we can do this in our
little parser with what we have so let's
take a look back at our code
second round maybe you know the first
step is the lexer right we're gonna try
and use our regular expressions but I
don't see a way for us to be able to use
just these regular expressions and be
able to maintain some connection between
the N and the the channel that we're
looking in or the from and the person
there's no way to maintain the
connection between the modifier and
their entity but what we do know is how
to decompose a in token into its
modifier and its entity we know that
production rule so if we can just you
know say okay this is our parser we do
what we want to we know how to take and
in token and then we're tokenizing we
know how to take it's like lex IAM and
split it apart we know that an in token
the modifier is going to be an in
modifier and we know that the filter is
going to be this particular entity which
is anything after the in filters pull in
and maybe a space so we know how to
break these two things apart because we
know the production rule for turning and
in token into its modifier and its
entity so why not this is our parser
then we can then make a mini tree out of
this in token and then we can you know
in our parse step we still have these
tokens that all roll up into that query
and we end up getting a tree that is a
little bit more complicated let's do so
our tree is going to be one more layer
deep in token now turns into a modifier
and an entity cool cool all right so now
we're gonna get into a little bit more
theory which is what this was all
building up to why was the regex enough
for the first example but not for the
second you know there's a lot going on
here
seems pretty powerful right we were able
to pretty much capsule
everything that we needed to do our
parse for our first smaller language but
once we added that extra layer the
regular expression wasn't enough anymore
to be able to really encapsulate the
entire languages grammar that's because
the first language that we had was a
regular grammar that grammar was able to
be described by this most simple type of
language which is called a regular
language that has a regular grammar and
all the production rules are of the
following type you have the thing on the
left can be broken down farther it is
called a non-terminal gonna be a lot
easier for me to use that term and then
thing on the right is cannot be broken
down any further and it is called a
terminal the other way that a rule can
look is that a terminal can be broken
down into one non-terminal and one
terminal so if we take a look at our
Whittle language end up getting
something that looks like that either
have the non terminal on the left
turning into something that can't be
broken down any further or it turns into
a combination of just one thing that can
be broken down further and one thing
that could not be broken down any
further
but once we added in that next
production rule so we could break down
the filter into a modifier and entity
ended up not being able to describe this
with the regular grammar anymore so the
regular expression was no longer able to
be just our friend and we needed to add
an something else
that knew how to get that bit into our
language and allow us to represent that
as the structure that we needed so the
next level of complexity in languages is
called a context-free grammar it has
rules that follow this these rules so
alpha it's a little bit you know
intimidating but all the means is that
it's any combination of things that can
be broken down further and things that
cannot be broken down further and it's
just a little bit more power that lets
us do a lot more things so the classic
example here is that now we can
do you nesting which includes matching
parentheses so regular expressions can't
do this because they don't have any
concept of memory whereas we need to
know if like verify if we indeed do have
matching parentheses if when we see a
closing parentheses if we'd seen the
opening one earlier and not seen or
maybe we'd seen another opening one
beforehand but we need to have some type
of memory to know if we are actually
closing something based on the rules of
the grammar that's why you might have
heard that HTML isn't possible by
regular expressions might be really
tempting such a simple language of
course it should be possible by regular
expressions that's again because of the
nesting we need to know if our divs are
closing properly so I mean you might be
thinking oh but like look ahead in
regular expressions it's because regular
expressions these days are more power
powerful than just a regular grammar so
they have that little bit of memory
that's necessary to give it that little
extra boost and and make them just a
little bit more powerful than just a
normal regular grammar so HTML like most
if not all programming language grammars
fall into the context-free family so you
can do a lot with just this little extra
bit of power that this little stack of
memory that these parsers have so I've
been talking a lot about like oh this is
like a toy parser this isn't necessarily
how these things necessarily work in the
real world it's because writing one by
hand would be a little bit
time-consuming most of the time if
you're gonna build a parser for a
language you have a program that builds
the purse or for you which is called a
purse or generator so let's just go into
what these things are doing at a higher
level so if we were doing this following
the more like suitable way of doing it
we would end up lexing those terms down
into their leaves so you would end up
with these terms and then the modifier
and entity would be their own lexemes
and tokens in the end then the next
thing that the parser
going to do is go through and match the
tokens to production rules there's a
bunch of ways for doing this but let's
step through one which is the top-down
method so we're gonna take the tokens
and then we're gonna start with the
highest level of non-terminal that we
have which is a query you know the
queries can be broken down into other
things in a myriad of different ways
let's just say we got lucky and we chose
the one that was going to work for our
language first right off the bat so we
say okay query can be broken down into a
term and another query does that work
with the tokens that we have at hand yes
yes it does we can't break down a term
anymore
we can't break down a query anymore
let's try that rule again cool that
worked for us because we were able to
pop that term off of our list of tokens
feeling lucky let's try that rule again
oh no didn't work we don't have another
term let's try the next rule Oh looks
like we got maybe lucky this time
because let's let you know let's see
what is a filter it can be turned into a
modifier and an entity oh cool we got
lucky
that was like best-case scenario I think
we only had to backtrack once okay
so running out of time luckily I've
reached the end of the talk I hope if
you've learned anything it's that a
parser is just something that takes
unstructured language and turns it into
structured language based on the grammar
that that language is that the grammar
for that language when I started this
talk I wanted to learn more about
parsers and once I realized that and I
was building my own it became a lot more
let give it a lot less intimidating so I
hope if anything you take that away and
maybe one day you'll have to write your
own search query parser so you'll have
this under your belt and then maybe you
want to write your own JavaScript parser
that's cool too
hope this helped you so thank you for
your time feel free to tweet at me and
you can find my slides at that link
thanks again
[Applause]